yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn comm / yang
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have a take on weather cancel a
culture is like like at the right place
a little bit overboard still more work
to be done yeah you know I I go back and
forth on that but yeah I don't I'm not
for somebody does one thing wrong and
then we banished them I mean in your
case it's more complicated - for the
fact that you actually know a lot of
people as human beings and there's like
a natural temptation if you know some as
a human being you'd be like oh like I
know that person looks like a human
being sometimes you know the human being
you know like oh that person is an
[ __ ]
yeah actually okay and I was just some
really dumb thing you know I wish we had
a finer way to distinguish between those
two situations you can see you can you
can see the where people that people
don't come to the to their defense but
when people come out and say like hey
come on I guys not like that I'll come
this person is good person there and
then you know it's like okay come on
this somebody just made a slip is fool
leave them alone
[Music]
I am thrilled to welcome the yang speaks
the incredible comedian writer author
actress activist you name it what hasn't
she done Wanda Sykes welcome Wanda it's
great to see you great to have you here
oh thank you thanks for having me on
I mean do I have to do right well we
were just talking about how the fact
your wife and kids are in France and
you're here in the States with us and
we're all thinking like wow
the French are smart not letting us in
terrible that we're all you know looking
up to the rest of the world because I
think at this point they're through the
worst of it they're probably reopening
your your families probably sending you
pictures of everyone outside oh man my
kids they went to an amusement park the
ride rollercoasters but but they're also
you don't wear that we're in the mass
but they yeah the bowling alley I mean
they're I mean you know how many
journeys get passed at a bowling alley
but they're in there having a great time
I mean they did the right thing you know
early on well it's good for them not so
good for us so in your case you're
probably a little bit like me where like
I'm a patriotic American I'd feel a
little bit bad about like you know going
someplace else even though like on a
rational level it would make sense it in
your case your wife's family is from
France oh so that makes a world of sense
so one of the the things I know we have
in common is the poor people's March
that happened it was meant to happen
live in DC did you connect with Reverend
barber like during that time and like
how did you get it connected with the
March well I followed him one you know
on social media and I guess I liked
enough of his post that retweeted off
his things that he he slid into my DMS
and he asked me if I would you know join
and participate and I was like
absolutely because I believe and what
you know what
doing what they stand for yeah me too
I had a chance to sit down with Reverend
barber during the campaign they got some
of the presidential candidates to talk
about our plans on poverty and it was
incredible to me how frankly in my mind
like underappreciated that movement was
where for all of the good they're doing
I mean at this point they're speaking to
the real-life situation of 7080 percent
of Americans at this point like you know
half of whom can't afford an unexpected
four hundred dollar bill everyone's
living paycheck to paycheck and I love
the fact that they're trying to take dr.
King's teachings and philosophies and
implement them now decades later I mean
it's it's decades overdue in my mind and
it's something that you know I was
thrilled to see you working working on
with them because to me that message is
hitting home really powerfully right now
like we have a chance to actually make
some changes in a big way because of the
fact that so many people are struggling
oh absolutely and really when you think
about it that was like dr. King and some
of his the most radical list you know
ideas that that he had and and a lot of
people think that's what made him even
more dangerous and probably what you
know causes assassination when he's you
know trying to unite people on or such a
basic level you know and
and I think it's it's just like you said
the decades overdue because it's just
just a basic idea there you work 40
hours a week and you still living below
poverty it's just it's especially in
this country it's like it that should
automatically be like hey something's
wrong here this is not how how we should
be as a country yeah it's it's
incredible how much we've been
brainwashed we're even like the language
people have argues around the same thing
where it's like hardworking Americans or
like people are trying to work and and
one of the things I said on the trail
all the time and you know this as a
parent now is like you know who works
harder than me as my wife who's with the
kids one of whom is autistic and that
kind of work isn't really attributed any
economic value and when people talk
about like Oh hardworking Americans
they're always talking about the
nine-to-five that forty hour work week
that isn't a reality for most of us
anymore like we don't have an economy
where you wake up and go to the factory
and like you work from 9:00 to 5:00 and
then you punch out know at this point
those jobs are getting done by machines
you know like more and more people are
working in these gig temp jobs where
you're at the whim of you know the uber
or the lyft or whatever it is you're
working for you don't get benefits you
don't have a real path forward and like
we're pretending like the economy still
works the way it did in the 70s so the
fact that dr. barber and you and others
were taking that that caused to DC Mena
you know I would have loved to have seen
how many people we could have gotten out
if not for the fact that we're in the
time of kovat because I know it was
virtual but what was your experience
like with them so my part was mainly you
just point out that the majority you
know of poor people is made up of women
and children were hit the hardest and
it's like you were saying a lot of women
make up for uh you know take care of the
homes and it's work that doesn't you
know doesn't count here
and and also to me I thought that the
approach was was right the way they did
it because instead of you know us who
we're not in that category we're not you
know we're not struggling we're we're
pretty blessed to step aside and just
let the people who are actually in these
situations to let them tell their
stories and I think that's what was so
effective is using our our platforms to
shine a light to let these people speak
to like they say to give them a voice
and I think that's to me that's what I
drew me to learn to work with them
because I might look I'm not gonna stand
up here and talk about you know what
it's like to be poor I mean am i a
generation away from that you know but
yeah but still I think we need to hear
from people who you know who are who are
suffering that yeah which is most of
most of America at this point right
[Music]
so here in yang speaks we care a lot
about data would think that our data is
getting sold and resold and we're
getting packetized and commoditized in a
way that's really bad for democracy and
mental health and lot of other things
and we're not seeing a dime of it it's a
drag and they're keeping track of
everything we do so what do you do about
it
one way to do it is to use Express VPN
and VPN stands for virtual private
network all these high-end companies
insist that their employees use VPNs so
that it's like they're logging into safe
and secure server no matter if they're
at home or at a Starbucks or whatever
the heck it is and you can do the same
thing and this way your internet
activities anonymous they can't track
you they can't sell and resell it so if
you want to protect your online activity
today with the VPN rated number one by C
net and wired visit expressvpn dot-com
slashing and you can get an extra three
months for free on a one-year package
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash yang
expressvpn dot-com slash yang to learn
more I'm literally using this right now
to stream our podcast ads in our podcast
so it doesn't slow down your video and
audio have no issues with it
expressvpn comm slash yang get your
discount it's freaking fantastic check
it out
[Music]
[Applause]
so as Vice President Biden called you to
you know just a pick your brain get some
advice as far as like his platform got a
call I've got a call later this week
with two people who are working on his
tech policy so we're gonna put our heads
together on that and I talked to Joe
last week because I co-hosted an event
for him but when I talked to Joe you
know we've we bonded a fair amount over
the fact that the middle class may
appear because our economy is changing
in various ways and he was one of the
first people actually this was months
ago
during one of the early debates where he
came to me like during one of the breaks
of the debate and and said yeah and then
after he said that he then said yeah we
should really do something about this
for the industrial revolution because
I'm scared that it's gonna straight the
middle class and then please yeah and
then but the back to the commo thing
yeah so so Joe and I have talked
extensively about the nature of the
problem when I see him now like because
I impart wanna this is funny like I'm
someone that I believe he is looking to
to try and address like tech and
economy-related issues but I've been in
his shoes as a candidate and when you're
the candidate like you have so much
stuff that you need to do in balance
that like the last thing you necessarily
need is someone coming and being like
hey I'm gonna now like tell you what's
what with like this issue or this issue
like Jesus got like you know he's gotta
like do what his team's telling them so
I'm plugged in to the to the Biden team
and I talked to Joe like you know
periodically but like I don't try and
like do a brain dump into him because
like I understand what what he's facing
I mean we got a freakin
we had a freaking ride Joe and his team
through the finish line November and
then get Trump the hell out of there and
then we can all get our heads together
and figure out how to rebuild this
country that's now devastated on
multiple levels but yeah I saw Joe last
week and on the trail I'll tell you the
random story I know why I'm not sharing
this but I thought it was really pretty
wise so new hampshire candidates we're
all doing our things blah blah blah and
then paul giamatti comes up and he
essentially was like a political tourist
where he decided just I'm gonna watch
like half a dozen different candidates
do their things in like little little
gatherings because we all had little
gatherings scheduled so Paul just like
hopscotch around to like different like
different events just so you do it all
in there too
and when you're in that context as a
candidate as I was like you run into Joe
by accident like every few weeks in in
one of the early states and and so Joe
and I would run into each other every
few weeks really for the like the last
two years in my case because I declared
really early I was running around waving
my flag before anyone was paying any
attention and that Joe the guy joy
didn't like all the sudden like there
were periods when I was definitely
getting big footed by other candidates
where it'd be like a drag here but never
mind about him Joe was here there was
that yeah so Joe Joe and I are in touch
and I'm very like you I'm very very
excited about him defeating Donald Trump
in just a few months yes yes I know it
was like we gotta get behind him I was
like we had to get behind them in front
of them on the side of them
we got a prop him up and get him through
there man cuz yes not we cannot do it do
more this well people who know my
thinking on this like I think Joe is
gonna win truly like I think so many of
us are really shell-shocked to be like
oh snap like Trump you
pulled it off once before like he might
like pull it off again and you know the
there's some uncertainty around the vote
but any objective analysis to me is like
Joe's gonna win like we've got 72
percent of Americans who say this is the
worst time in American history since
they've been alive that's not exactly a
climate where everyone's like yeah like
I want four more years it is people who
boarded my truck were like this sucks
like this is pretty terrible so I think
Joe's gonna win but you and I and other
people have to try and make sure it
happens like we got to do the work yeah
absolutely and and like the people
especially young African Americans and
who were you know out protesting gotta
get them to the polls people get me they
got that same energy I mean we got a
face facts this is a binary decision
like it's gonna be absolutely Trump or
President Biden and we got to make it
President Biden and I'll tell you like
having hung out with Joe he's open to
different points of view like he's not
like like a particularly ideological guy
like he's looking around being like okay
like what's the plan so I am gonna be
chiming in on some tech policy a little
later this week happily with the folks
that like the that are helping to craft
that I think that there are major issues
around technology that we need to play
catch up on
[Music]
this is a uniquely and distinctly
stressful anxiety-ridden time for us all
and you got to take care of yourself
right now you have to try and get
exercise and have a routine and get some
structure but even after all that you
know also help is having someone to talk
to and I don't mean like zooming your
buddy and being like hey you know what's
up talking to Zach all the time I mean
like talking to someone about the fact
that that [ __ ] sucks that maybe you know
you're feeling some degree of negative
emotion that it's new to you and I'm
thrilled to say that right now we we
have a new sponsor the podcast better
help calm that will actually hook you up
with therapists and resources online
it's convenient professional affordable
you just find a licensed professional
counselor or who just talk you through
stuff and as usual we have a deal for
you but over a million people are
already using better help
that's heelp calm and if you go to
better help calm slash yang you'll get
10% off your first month by being one of
our podcast listeners so that's better
help a TLP calm slash yang to get
yourself some help
and there's absolutely no shame nothing
negative no stigma about it I mean I I
saw a counselor when I was in high
school and after that I said everyone
should have one of these all the time
forever so yeah get yourself some help
it better help calm slash yang so we're
I'll say in our own organization and
rude humanity forward we're now in what
month 4/5 of working from home and I
would say the entire team self included
we're all collectively losing our minds
no offense guys if you're listening but
it's true so I've recommended this to
our team and to use it there because
geez man like the world's burning we're
all helped they're stuck inside we have
to stare at screens all day long
the lack of like hope and optimism
is something we're trying to overcome on
this podcast but it's still real so
that's better help HG LP better help
calm slashing and get 10% off your first
month's and a welcome you as a Yank
speaks listener hope you guys check it
out so one thing I wanted to talk to you
about one is like you're like one of the
trailblazers in so many ways like you
went and and carved this incredible path
for yourself you eventually come out as
homosexual and it sounded like that was
a difficult process because your family
was quite conservative you're married
have beautiful family 11 year old twins
and and then you were a writer on
Roseanne and like they had this this
issue where obviously like that like
Roseanne ended up having some terrible
statements that I came out on Twitter
and then I believe you left that show
but on the same time like I see your
comedy in your comedy is so real like
your comedy is like no punches being
pulled like Wanda Sykes is like you know
just like telling it like it is be real
and there's so many comedians from your
era that have issues with the fact that
it seems like the the goalposts keep
moving for comedy or the goalposts keep
moving for art generally where like if
artists were to talk about certain
things X years ago we'd all be like yeah
that's fine
but now it seems like the rules have
shifted and and you again are like one
of the original Trailblazers of the era
you've seen and done it all like do you
have a take on whether cancel a culture
is like like at the right place a little
bit overboard still more work to be done
you know I I go back and forth on that
it to me it's it's it's up to the
audience the audience gets to decide
who's canceled and who's been who's not
I mean we can all say hey that's wrong
this person this person should you know
should go away
be canceled but if that person you know
says hey I'm doing a show and people in
the audience shows up at my last tickets
to see that person then who are we to
say you know you're wrong that you
you're not allowed to you know to
support or this is the comic that you
like you know no we're not gonna allow
allowed this to happen if that person is
not for you then fine then don't don't
go see them don't go support them but
yeah I don't I'm not for somebody does
one thing wrong and then we banished
them oh particularly in comedy and just
as a human being - and as a presidential
candidate I can share this you stick a
mic in my face often enough like
eventually I'll say something really
stupid humanity like absolutely and as a
candidate like that there was very much
that dynamic where people it almost
seems like they're trying to get you to
say something problematic so they can be
like see look at this person and look at
this statement and so that they like ask
you questions that you could tell are
meant to try and like get a rise out of
you or somewhat like contentious and
then like as a candidate you had to
essentially just like just check any
kind of humanity at the door in terms of
like an emotional response because if
you were react emotionally that it's
like oh like then like we got him
because he reacted harshly when we like
suddenly insinuated that he was you know
like a racist or a terrible person or
whatever the situation was and so so I
understood these that part of it as a
candidate it's like like okay
I get it but like if you catch anyone on
film and like their worst moments like
we'd all look freaking terrible you know
like this does human beings and so then
if you say it's like look I have this
this moment of this person saying
something regrettable so let's try and
expunge their existence from you know
like the culture or
that from social media or whatnot but
what you said initially to me was like
the way it used to be which is like hey
I don't like your art I don't like your
comedy so I will not watch or consume it
and I will just make sense I mean that
made sense to me but now there's like a
new thing it's like I don't like what
you're saying and now I will somehow
condemn you I will somehow try and tell
others that like if you're associated
this person there's another part of it
to that like that there's like this
strange supposed to be like transferal
of attitudes or beliefs like if you said
something that I disagreed with and I
said had this conversation with you then
I'm also actually in the wrong because
like I'm going to somehow be either
getting your attitudes and beliefs from
you or somehow like helping you transfer
them to to others and it's like can't
people just have a conversation and like
not like imagine that I agree with
everything that is saying I mean happens
in real life all the time like you know
I talked to my neighbor my neighborhood
thinks all sorts of stuff that I'm
probably not a fan of but it's like
still talk over the feds and you know
like no no problems were had so I'm with
with you on that level it's like the the
negation of your own consumption like a
okay but then like the negation of
anyone's consumption it's like come on
people should be able to to see what
they want to see right I mean in your
case it's more complicated to for the
fact that you actually know a lot of
people as human beings and there's like
a natural temptation if you know
someone's a human being you'd be like
like I know that person looks like a
human being sometimes you know the human
being you're like oh that person is an
[ __ ] actually okay and I was just
some really dumb thing you know I wish
we had a finer way to distinguish
between those two situations you can see
you can you can see the but we're people
that people don't come to the to their
defense
yeah everybody's okay finally God oh but
when when people come out and say like
hey come on that guy's not like that
I'll come watch this person is good
person there and then you know it's like
okay come on this somebody just made a
slip it's cool
leave them alone yeah well that that's
encouraging Wanda well you know we
should definitely like you know take a
beat and look around and be like had
anyone come to this person's different
because if so like me I'll just like
wait a day to like decide whether I
think that I mean I could be like at
least an improvement over the current
process I need in an ideal world and
this this happens to me to an ideal
world you'd actually like this is not
realistic but this is the ideal you
actually just be able to call a person
up and be like hey so what's up like
what was that about
like here we're what the backstory was
of course we never had that
opportunities and and a lot of times
someone's career is on line so then
they'll end up having like a very like
rehearsed crafted statement and they're
the rest of it which in some ways is
really unfortunate because you kind of
want someone to be like all right like
you know this was the deal yeah exactly
the ones that are so crafted well
crafted they they feel so fake and you
know the person is just saying it to try
to save their career you know then this
then you're like man this is not this is
not going to do it but I'd rather for
somebody to say something if they say
something you know stupid whatever
racist whatever and make it called out
on it gonna go wait no what was wrong
when I said you know I rather put them
to start at that point like what was
wrong with it
so at least now people to say well
because it's this this this and they go
oh why do you think that but okay I can
see it okay my bad
I'm sorry I will you know at least you
you're you see that there's a there's
some growth there they're learning
something but don't apologize if you
don't know what you're apologizing for
there are parallels to politics again
with this because
you see also like the very very polished
statements where like you know someone
misspeaks if there's a gaffe and then
it's like oh like I'm really really
sorry and like area like the things I
mean this happened to me on the trail to
where you know like I was accused of
doing something and then these
consultants on my campaign team were
like alright you need to apologize this
immediately and I was like so you wanna
ask me whether this actually happened or
what was a real thing you want to check
out that and then then after they
checked with eventually it was somewhat
I said that they were like is this real
and I was like it is not real and
apologizing for it is like the opposite
of what we should do because it happens
to be completely untrue and like I got
the sense too that the consultants just
assumed it was true because probably
they've been around other situations
where it was true probably it but but
also like that's like their knee-jerk
reaction because they're like trying to
protect the that they're trying to
protect like the institution or the
franchise you know like in this case it
was like hey I was a candidate I raised
millions of dollars they're getting paid
by me and I didn't have that many
consultants they really disliked
consultants but we had a couple for
media stuff and some other things and so
when they came out with his guidance
like they're just trying to protect the
franchise and and meanwhile didn't even
check with a human being to be like hey
like we can somehow humanize these
communications and do what you just
suggested where the person's like what's
wrong with what I said like can someone
explain to me like where I went wrong
and then you know have like a little bit
more of like a human education process
because like that there's like a real
there's like faux shame you know you can
sense it in some of these communications
and it's preceded by this faux outrage
where it's like like are people that
like actually like upset by what this
person said like half the time it [ __ ]
that someone says around you casually
like you know but they're not a public
figure obviously it's just some you know
some knucklehead
like says it around you would like you
don't go around like you know like
braiding like you know you're freaking
like uncle or a grandfather whatever it
happens to be and so that gives us like
so there's like a faux outrage and it
like rises up and then there it's
followed by like this faux penance or a
faux shame and it's like you know I will
think I will reflect I'll retreat into
my cave I will you know do the stuff
it's like you know we need to like tamp
both of those reactions down ideally oh
absolutely yeah
the fake anger to fake it just bugs me
you know it's just the worst because
it's like I know you don't give a [ __ ]
about this but you just just feel like
you're this is how you're the right way
I should react you know but really
what's so ridiculous about all this is
that Trump has said some of the most the
most offensive [ __ ] ever
I mean grab a bite of [ __ ] I mean it
you start there and he still became
president so it seems like everybody
should get at least three we should all
get like just three you get you you can
you can say whatever crazy [ __ ] you want
to say three times in nobody can mess
with
[Applause]
okay so if you're like us you listen to
music and maybe you have that headset
but you're noticing some folks around
you have these earbuds or the air pods
or these like Wireless things you're
like wow maybe I should get myself some
of those but maybe you're daunted by the
fact that some of them are really
expensive now
we were sent some recon earbuds and
they're like the sweet spot where
instead of breaking the bank they
started about half the price of the the
earbuds that have been scaring you off
you know I've got a pair right now in my
hand in my ears was one in each it's a
sort of bizarre but they work great they
actually are really snug and indiscreet
like people can't even tell you have
them on necessarily and they're freaking
beautiful stylish celebrities love them
so some of the celebrities that use them
because like I kind of like some of
these people Snoop Dogg cardi B and jr.
Smith you know NBA champion JR Smith use
these ear buds so they are the sweet
spot I'm a fan Rey Khan's
ear buds hit the mark now's the time to
get their new everyday air buds and you
can get 15% off your order at buy recon
comm slash yang that's by recon comm
slash yang for 15% off recon wireless
earbuds you can join the future you
could be one of those cool people or
annoying people that around you that
have made you feel deficient soon you
will make others feel deficient at recon
comm slash yeah I'd say this I bought
the expensive ear buds and I've lost
them then I feel like I've lost it's
like losing a cellphone these are not
that you you know designed to lose them
but if you do lose them they're less
expensive and with us you get a pretty
good discount
so by rake on Comm slash yang get 15%
off buy as many as you can and they
sound great great gifts too great great
yes yeah give the gift of rake on
[Music]
it was funny Wanda because like I was
new to politics and I'm like a recently
minted public figure where you know like
no one knew who the hell Andrew yang was
not that long ago and so the lessons you
learned when you were coming up in the
you know like the 90s and becoming a
public figure like I kind of got
downloaded into me very very quickly and
a compressed time frame you know like it
and you figure them out because like I'm
adaptive and I was like all right I'm
trying to get a job done and in my case
the job was to try and abolish poverty
and get universal basic income across
the finish line I don't know if you have
a viewpoint on universal basic income as
something that we should adopt oh
absolutely I mean I I agree with it yeah
I don't know why like I understand why
people would be against it or way just
like we're just not aware as we don't
talk about enough of how like with with
what with the what they did with the
koba's situation give all this money to
corporations and I read it was like a
guy who owns a a private jet company he
got like 27 million dollars but that's
fine but then we say hey can we extend
another $1,200 to you know to
individuals the people they they're like
we can't just be giving away free money
as welfare why did they attack the poor
people people really need it and it's
like rich people it just sickens them to
think of rich people not being rich like
they might actually have to cut back on
something exactly I mean I guess you
know if I was in a situation I guess
it's like oh no cuz that's like taking
my money I I don't understand it it's so
I mean why do understand it but I just
think it's just disgusting how how we
operate in this and
country what a high-five you're for
universal basic income this makes me so
happy I'm gonna give you an air
high-five over the zoom this is and I
couldn't agree more
I mean of the three trillion dollars we
just printed like less than fifteen
percent of it went to us it's like that
like they just freakin forked over tens
hundreds of billions of dollars to these
mega corpse and I understand how these
systems work where like if you just gave
us money and then there were these
businesses that then were frankly like
you know having massive problems because
like that they like you don't have to go
bankrupt that would be actually okay
like that's what the bankruptcy system
is for you know like you could go and
then rationalize like and I'm not
actually for this it's like I'm okay
with trying to put our economy and
suspended animation but you start with
the people it's like you don't put the
companies in suspended animation so that
the private jet company gets like tens
of millions and then the person who
worked at that airfield like refueling
jets for like 10 bucks an hour like goes
home and like has no idea what the hell
to do right you know like that that's
like the screwed up part and like I
agree with you that there is some kind
of preservation of the status quo that's
like embedded it in what like what's in
legislators minds where it's like oh
you're a mega Corp like you can't go
bust like that would be unfathomable but
then like that person working at that
airfield like them going bust it's like
and people have caught on to the
[ __ ] and like that that's one of
like the great things about the stimulus
and this is a terrible time and like you
know like it breaks my heart all the
suffering and pain and and you know
death but the myth that we didn't have
enough money to go around everyone's
like what the hell are you talking about
cuz like you just freaking like you know
wrote a check for three trillion and
then people looking around being like
where why did I not get ranked more than
that $1200 I got spent weeks and months
ago
I mean 74% of Americans are for
emergency cash relief right now
including a majority of Republicans so
like why are we not giving cash to
people like we're still just looking at
plowing money and and
the government dropped the ball so
miserably on like co vid and like people
put all the blame on Trump and Trump
deserves like a ton of the blame because
he like really screwed things up at the
top but like you could legitimately look
around and being like wait a minute like
where where is the contact tracing where
is it testing it's not like you know
that they're like problems at every
level like III was looking in you
probably saw some of the headlines but
yeah like some of the government
failures I'm looking at being like like
you know this was like a like a mammoth
historic level failure that has us in
like this situation and you can't even
bail us out it's like you like leave us
in this state and that you're like and
you're gonna somehow like survive even
though like that you know your job like
disappeared for like last four months it
makes me so angry Wanda I'm thrilled
that you're Pro Universal basic income
that's like a freakin awesome awesome
thing absolutely I mean it's it always
amazes me how we're you know like when
I'm like talking about raising the
minimum wage whatever and then they
always throughout the argument of well
we can't we can't you can't make
companies and a bit small yeah they
always like you put on small business
can make small businesses pay employees
15 whatever dollars an hour they can't
afford as I well but maybe they should
be in business thing if maybe you need
to rethink your business plan raise your
prices whatever but but they always put
it on small business or or you know the
the little guys instead of what they're
saying is corporation is Walmart they
don't want to pay that money they don't
want to you know they don't want to pay
that outrageous but maybe those
businesses could pay 15 bucks an hour if
all of their customers had an extra a
couple thousand bucks a month
it spread to that business yeah yeah
we're like subsidizing like you said I
mean there was something around like
McDonald's or Walmart they like we're
instructing people how to access public
benefits it's like they knew they
weren't paying enough for folks to get
by or like and so and like the you know
the public has been subsidized
those businesses - like this massive
massive degree yeah like we so that this
is like the big hope I have I mean this
is a difficult tragic time but we have
to do things differently on the other
end and I think that after we get Trump
out of there
and Joe is in the White House we're
gonna get together and I mean you and me
as well we're gonna get together and be
like okay like how do we start doing
things differently and I'm doing
something that most Democrats you know
would like to rock sent me for whatever
but I'm already like planning for like
the Joe Biden victory like at this point
I'm thinking like okay like we're gonna
do the work we're gonna kick ass we're
gonna get young people excited we're
gonna get out there vote Joe's gonna win
I'm the math guy the numbers say Joe is
gonna win Coke is going to win and then
the question is like what then like then
really the work begins because we're
still gonna be in a real freakin mess
and we're gonna have to dig out we're
gonna need like a new new deal it's
gonna include universal basic income
like the green New Deal criminal
criminal justice reform and police
reform how the heck is there not a
George Floyd law on the books yet you
know I mean you literally had so many of
us like out there protesting on the
streets and you like still you know like
there's so much that needs to be done
it's one reason why I'm passionate too
about these down ballot races where you
have to try and get enough people in
there so that we can make real changes
because it's ridiculous that like again
74% of Americans want emergency cash and
like Congress just isn't getting its
[ __ ] together yeah come on come on Amy
you know let's do it
yeah I know you and I you know supported
other candidates initially in that race
you know I just texted with Charles
Booker actually yesterday but now it's
Amy so screw it
absolutely
yeah so I'm with
like it's a little bit like supporting
other candidates and now supporting Joe
it's like let's get real let's get
practical and let's let's get the right
people into Washington
[Music]
we're gonna talk about something that
you think about every waking moment
stamps maybe don't what you get every or
every waking moment but you dream about
them but you have to mail something
periodically I literally have to mail
something right now and the old way the
twentieth-century way is go to the post
office wait online do all that jazz so
what's the 21st century way stamps calm
you can order whatever you need you
essentially can have a post office on
your phone or computer they'll even send
you a freaking scale if you set up your
account and get discounts of up to 62
percent this is really just a smarter
way to mail stuff that's actually just
the truth of it we use stamps calm
religiously on the campaign trail
because there was a lot of postage
getting mailed out right now actually
business tip from Andrew yang apparently
right now people are reading their mail
at higher levels than normal so if
you're trying to reach people mailing
stuff is a good idea right now and right
now if you want to sign up for stamps
calm you can get a four week trial plus
free postage and that digital scale I
mentioned without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps calm click
on the microphone at the top of the page
type in yang that stamps comm and our
yang and then you too can enjoy 21st
century convenience with 20th century
post office goodness
[Music]
well one is such a pleasure talking to
you thank you for connecting do you have
anything that you're working on or like
an event that you're I'm going to be out
upcoming then you want to let people
know about well I have a show that's
sure when we're gonna get you know
released because we still have like
seven episodes to shoot but we're
shooting a show for Netflix Netflix
called the Upshaw's so that's a
difficult calculation for Netflix
because right now they're like we really
want to put new content out there real
bad we would love to put those five
episodes out but then they're like do we
wait until the gang gets back together
and makes the next seven episodes like
do you know how they make those
decisions I don't but my thought is that
they they want you to be able to promote
it so in this situation you know it's
kind of hard to hit all the late-night
shows and all the morning TV because you
know we're stuck in this quarantine
situation so is it hard or is it easy
not kidding like just go on into the
living room
be like Jimmy no I'm just kidding but
yeah I mean sharing I'm no Netflix like
has their algorithm they could consult
the mighty algorithm and say oh oh
technology like what do we do with the
first five episodes of the Upshaw's well
Wanda please do keep us posted so
thrilled that you're Pro universal basic
income and looking forward to
celebrating with you come January 2021
the way when they're when there's a new
president in the White House absolutely
let's do it
thank you for listening again I hope you
enjoyed this conversation it
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notification so we can let you
know every time we have a new episode
[Music]
[Applause]